thank you
so
we think the brain is a private place
and when we're sitting with our bosses
or our
spouses or our best friends we're very
grateful sometimes that it is and yet
science advances in science is making
that less and less true all the time
today we explore amazing research with
scientists who are at least at the
beginning stages of being able to decode
what's going on in our brains what we're
thinking identifying objects we're
looking at or even
just
imagining
also we'll look at related research
decoding brain patterns and using brain
machine interfaces that are being put to
use in the field of motor robotics
helping paralyzed patients locked in
patients move artificial limbs
communicate perform
many other functions and to bring us
that discussion let me introduce our
panelists first
john dylan haynes p h d bernstein center
bernstein center
bernstein center in berlin
john dillon is a professor of the
bernstein center for computation
computational neuroscience his major
focus is on decoding mental states from
human brain activity using pattern
recognition
frank tong he uh studies the neural
bases of
the neural bases of visual bases of
visual perception he's a phd vanderbilt
university associate professor of
psychology cognition and cognitive
neuroscience
he studies attention awareness
recognition working memory and he's
especially interested in problems of
brain reading and mind reading that is
whether measures of a person's brain
activity can be used
to read a person's visual thoughts
john donahue phd professor brown
university is a neuroscientist and
founding chair of the department of
neuroscience there his research includes
revolutionary advances in mind
controlled motor prosthesis that's
moving those artificial limbs and
restoring movement to the paralyzed
and paul root wolfie phd and and
professor at emory university he's the
director of the center for ethics there
his expertise and research interests are
in the area the very new area the area
that he created of neuro ethics
so
let's begin
john dillon
can you tell us what the headlines are
right now in your research
so in our research field over the last
couple of years it has emerged that you
can use brain scanners to decode what a
person is thinking with more and more
detail so a couple of years ago this
wouldn't have been thought possible and
now we can't just decode simple visual
images but we can also decode high-level
thoughts such as for example plans
action plans memories emotions and
things like that and that's i think
quite an exciting prospect it sounds
like you're talking about mind reading
well you could call it mind reading
although um the um reading might not be
quite true because that would imply that
we actually understand the language of
the brain so what we're doing is we're
kind of using brute force statistical
techniques to kind of decipher what a
person is thinking
but we can't actually
read the meaning of each individual
aspect of brain activity so we don't
understand the actual syntax and
semantics of the
neural activity
can you show us how this works
uh i could if i could see some slides
then i could
let's let's see that first slide so what
you can see here on the left is uh just
the mind reading of the 1900s so in
those days people were very fascinated
by the idea of kind of stage trick stage
magic and what you can see here is a
typical stage demonstration a person
comes out of the audience comes up on
the stage and this person with their
mind reading abilities is able to
draw figure that this person is thinking
of
and on the right what you can see here
is our current version you can see a
brain scanner and this brain scanner now
we could possibly read out what this
person is thinking of even though they
might not tell us what they're thinking
of we might be able to still read out
this information if we can decipher
their brain activity properly
well how are our conscious thoughts
encoded
well i'll show you
just a brief
example one more the next slide please
so this is the brain scan just to inform
you what a brain scanner is it's
ultimately a very strong magnet it's
like a coil magnet just that it has a
much stronger magnetic field in the
earth's magnetic field and if we could
show the next slide i don't know if i
can forward it with this it seems i
can't so what you can see here on the
left
is the typical patterns of brain
activity you get when people have
different thoughts say for example
thinking about a face a house and so on
and um
the meaning of your thoughts is encoded
in these patterns of brain activity and
what you have to do is you have to
somehow analyze this and for that you
can use something similar to what you
know from csi
so if you just could show the next
animation
just click once
we apply similar statistical techniques
that would normally use to decipher
fingerprints
and we train a pan and classifier to
recognize these patterns of brain
activity and with that we can then
find these individual thoughts it's very
similar to the idea of actually using a
fingerprint to recognize an individual
you have to you have a big database of
fingerprints and you've got names
associated with them and similar here
we take the spatial patterns of brain
activity and we can identify specific
thoughts that a person has as long as
they're in this database so when you
then if you could just show the next one
um
you measure a pattern of brain activity
and you don't know what this person is
thinking then your pattern classifier
just
guesses that this is most likely going
to be the one that is most similar so
statistically optimal techniques are
used for this and then you would in this
case for example guess that the person
is thinking about well you could
possibly guess it in the audience
the person is thinking does anyone have
an idea
exactly so um uh if you could just if
you could resolve it
you'll see did you press once more
yeah you can see it was actually a chair
well let me ask you then let me try and
decode what you've decoded here i see a
fingerprint that means that
these patterns the way that this
individual identifies a face a house a
chair a shoe
are unique to that individual or do we
see that kind of
can we extrapolate that lit up pattern
to other people that's a very very
interesting question actually i think
the field hasn't quite
gotten to answering this question at a
very coarse level of course if the
pattern of brain activity different
people see faces is very similar similar
to houses but as soon as you get into
the subtle details of a person's
thoughts say for example you want to
know which house which face
which chair which shoe or other subtle
aspects
then it seems that these fine-grained
details are encoded quite differently
from person to person and the reason is
that of course they're mixed with your
individual experiences with your history
that you have your emotional
connotations the thoughts that you kind
of associate with specific objects and
images
and that's why the these uh are encoded
differently in each person but yeah so
so far we can
we can only really know how that person
feels about a face
i think um it's not completely true so
you can
guess to a certain degree from a group
of people um uh how
you could decode the patterns of brain
activity from another person but as soon
as you get into the finer details then
you kind of lose this information what
about
intentions conscious thoughts i mean if
we get beyond the issue of
objects
how deeply can you probe using this kind
of
fmri technology well behind this stage
of course we had a brain scanner
installed that you didn't know of so we
were able to predict that you're going
to ask this question
and if you just press the next slide
so this is exactly a line of research
we've been looking at so in this case a
person uh was put in a scanner it's just
not shown in a scanner here for ease
and they were asked to at some point
that they could freely choose to press
either a left or right button so this is
a very simple intention it's not an
intention like am i going to go to new
york or washington but it's an intention
that is kind of crystallizes this idea
you can use your free will at this point
in time to decide either for left or
right and the question was would we be
able to read out this person's intention
and would we be able to read it out even
before they themselves know how they're
going to decide
and so that we could know when they made
up their mind we had a letter on a
screen that changed every half second so
they had to remember not basically when
they make up their mind they have to
remember which letter was on the screen
and just tells us there's like a tag
that tells us um when they've made up
their mind and then if you should yeah
the second here john john dylan because
i'm not sure that i'm following you
you're saying that you can predict how
somebody is going to behave
uh
by
studying how they make decisions over
time a particular decision
and how does the letter on the screen
figure into that the letter figures in
so basically it's very simple you're
there you're relaxing and at some point
when you feel the urge to do so you make
a spontaneous decision for left or right
and um we just want to know when you
made up your mind so the letter doesn't
really have any importance you could
just as well use a clock and you just
ask people when did you make up your
mind where was the clock when you made
up your mind and you say say for example
at 10 o'clock
and then we know okay this is when they
made up their mind this is when they
press the button and then we want to go
back in time from the point when they
made up their mind and see how early we
can predict how they're going to decide
even before they themselves know how
they're going to decide and if you bring
up the next
point you will see
that um this is a pattern of brain
activity so what you can see here these
are regions of the brain that are
involved in very high level mental
activity for example planning your
actions um and reflecting about yourself
and below that you can see like a
geometric pattern of brain activity and
this geometric pattern of brain activity
can tell us how someone is going to
decide before they themselves even know
what they're going to do so we find that
parts of the brain here they have
patterns of brain activity that emerge
that predict your decision even before
you yourselves you yourself know how
you're going to decide they give your
decision away before you know
but the degree of decision did i just
get there i am but the degree of
decision we're talking about the uh the
importance of the decision has to do
with a simple act right i mean can you
is this tech does this technology enable
you to predict
decisions of a more important nature at
this point well i think the difficulty
is not so much um predicting decisions
of a more important nature say for
example am i going to choose one college
or the other or something like that
really important lifetime decisions the
difficulty is to get the computer to
trained on these decisions so we have to
learn what the patterns of brain
activity are that emerge that give the
person's decisions away and of course a
lifetime decision can only be done once
you can't get a person to choose once
which college they're going to take and
then five minutes later ask them please
choose again which college you're going
to take and then five minutes later you
ask them again please choose again
you've had exactly that experience
they can sign up as volunteers
uh well then let me let me just ask you
what ultimately do you see is the value
of this research
well i think the value of this research
is that it shows that you can decode not
just simple visual aspects of visual
information process i'm sure frank is
going to talk about but we can also get
at something that's more closely related
to kind of
behaviorally important
information of course now one of the
next things we're going to look into is
how you could decode something more
closely related to day-to-day behavior
for example
say your plan to go to the post office
before you go home or something like
that so if we can read out these more
everyday
intentions um that will be uh fantastic
and i think this helps us pinpoint the
brain areas where we can find this
information
we're going to be discussing the ethics
of all of this later but i just want to
plant a little bit of a seed here
can
this does this technology
ultimately lead
to the kind of uh
privacy invasions that people are
worried about can this
can you build a better lie detector that
way can you uh
can you find out what that person hates
let's say if they have a
racial issue or something like that will
that be evident in the in the scans that
you do i mean can you
get down to that level things of
consequence that people might not want
others to know i think one issue is what
can we do now and what are we going to
be able to do in the future and i think
at the moment we can't do too much i
mean this is still very basic research
but i think what the basic research
shows is that it's feasible to decode
things that you would have never
considered possible
and now you might
find that the applications side of this
is going to be much easier than we would
have thought a couple of years ago
because a lot of these applications you
don't need to read out like very
fine-grained details of a person's
thoughts say if you want to build a lie
detector you just want to know deception
yes no or if you want to build a neural
marketing
give asks can we predict a purchase
decision from the brain uh you want to
know are they going to buy the car yes
or no so a lot of these simple
applications
are feasible from this i think i think
we're still going to take a couple it's
going to take us a couple of years to
develop applications like these
and of course we also have to ask the
question if you want to develop these
applications
well before we move on to frank
can you tell us what it is that the fmri
measures when we all
know that an mri a conventional mri
measures
uh
the structure of your brain if there are
any abnormalities if there are any
lesions an mri could see that but yours
measures something else
well to a rough approximation what we
measure is the change in the oxygenation
level of the blood so when neurons fire
they need oxygen and this oxygen gets
taken out of the blood and then the
brain replenishes the blood uh the
oxygen and then uh this changes the
magnetic properties um of the blood and
this is something we can pick up with a
scanner so it's a rather indirect
measure of neural activity we can't
actually get to individual neurons
um the information we pick up is is kind
of course we have a resolution of three
millimeters roughly um and of course we
don't get down
brain function it's an after effect but
still
it's closely correlated with brain
activity but of course
we'd be able to get at much more
information if we were able to record
the activity of single neurons but this
is not possible the techniques that we
and that frank uses are restricted to
non-invasive techniques where we don't
open the skull we can't implement
electrodes in the brain of course we
don't want to do that so we're always
limited
well
i tell you
let me uh let me move on to frank now
frank i know your work is uh very much
in in parallel with john dylan's uh
except that you're seem to be at work
decoding
visual images images that people take in
and store in their brain and even images
that they can imagine that's right so
we know a great deal about the visual
system but from both animal studies and
human studies so it's a great test bed
to look at just how much information can
we squeeze out from the brain using
these non-invasive methods and how
detailed of a picture can we get of what
people are either seeing
paying attention to or even imagining
and so uh that's what my lab's pushing
towards to try to understand how visual
thoughts are represented in the brain
and uh in in one of our early studies if
i can uh go to my first slide um
the oh let's see let's go back
what we did here was uh we tried to
figure out whether we could read out
what orientations a person's seeing and
i'll quickly describe two important
properties of the human visual system
orientation
you mean the position that they're in or
i'll explain that so imagine
uh sorry i seem to have a lot of
feedback here should i move a little bit
um
by orientation i mean um uh sorry what's
represented in the visual brain imagine
if you just kept your eyes fixed is that
the pattern of light that hits your
retina is mapped uh onto the visual
cortex in a global core scale map so
this point of light would be represented
somewhere this one somewhere else this
was somewhere else
and on top of that
at uh at a fine scale is a
representation of orientation so at this
particular point let's say if we present
a little set of stripes and we just
rotated them around what we'd see is
that that would activate a tiny little
column maybe just half a millimeter wide
that would swirl around a pinpoint
and so
when we measure signals from the human
brain we're measuring with these really
large sort of three millimeter chunks
let's say we can get finer than that but
we can't resolve the representation of
orientation in the brain and one thing
that my lab has pushed is how far can
pattern recognition take us to read out
a signal that we might think would
otherwise be
invisible
to our methods
i can only speak for myself but i think
you lost me somewhere along the way and
i wonder if you could just roll back a
little bit and and explain
what orientation is one more time so
orientation is like uh what's vertical
what's horizontal uh what is a different
tilt it is the most basic feature that's
represented in the visual system it's
the way you see the outline of a bottle
the uh the lines of the face it is the
the most basic unit by which we
represent visual information in the
cortex
and uh if we can understand how to read
that out we can get a lot of information
potentially out from the brain so what
pattern recognition can do i was just at
the at moma today and i was looking at
some jackson pollock paintings so if you
have uh an array of all that array of
different colors represent neurons that
like different orientations
in any given patch maybe of just
slightly more black than white paint in
the patch next to it more
a different proportion by applying
pattern recognition we can read out uh
what orientation a person's seeing with
let's say uh 95 accuracy really high
accuracy for which of two orientations a
person seeing
um looking at the same sorts of pictures
that john dylan looks at these are
pictures of
you know oxygenation of cells
and
you're identifying the same sorts of
patterns that that his subjects
uh
that emerged when his subjects looked at
shoes and houses and faces and so forth
it's an earlier part of the brain that
represents this more basic information
but let me step forward so
it's interesting that we can read out
the orientation which only exists at a
fine scale even though we're measuring
these core scale patterns um
uh but what we wanted the next test is i
call that an example of brain reading
we're just reading out what the person's
seeing that's kind of cool but i could
also just look over the person's
shoulder and say oh they're looking at
this pattern rather than that pattern
so you know how their brain lights up
when they look at a cat exactly and and
decoding a cat from a dog
from visual cortex could be easier to do
than this angle of lines versus this
angle so it's a hard test case what we'd
like to know is whether we can read out
what a person is paying attention to
this is an example of reading out
something about mental thought and
tension so in this case if we ask people
to pay attention to
the white set of lines or the blacks
that aligns we can read out what
orientation they're paying attention to
with high accuracy not just uh what
they're seeing
suggesting that
we can read out something about the
person's uh attentional state or what
what is it they're focusing on
other groups have uh further focused on
uh what it is how far can we push this
technique if we make use of the fact
that these different global patterns on
the retina lead to different activations
in the visual cortex so in this study it
gets a little complicated but
essentially every little spot in your
visual cortex responds to a different
part of the visual field and if you
present let's say a thousand or two
thousand different pictures just say
random pictures selected from google
each of those will create a unique
pattern of activity in your brain and
what this group showed
was that they could based on these
activation patterns predict a novel
pictures that the person saw so at tests
they showed 120 different pictures and
they could correctly predict which
picture the subject was seeing 110 times
so with a really really high accuracy
and what you see um
in the uh
the sort of scatter plot there where
there's a sharp red along the diagonal
is uh their ability to predict the
correct image
so along the the one axis would be uh
the image that they saw and along the
other axis is the predicted image and
the fact that everything falls on that
diagonal means that they're they're
getting it right most of the time
can i ask you about uh
imaginary
images that emerge from the imagination
you can read those and you can interpret
those based on how their brain lights up
in an um in an fmri yeah so do you know
can you tell if somebody is imagining a
cat
we we can actually tell if that cat is
leaning to the left or leaning to the
right with regard to orientation i think
if if we focus on that we could do that
um i'll take you through uh
again the cat's a little bit easier i
know it sounds less realistic but it's a
little easier trying to make it easy for
me not for you but uh you can you can
come up with anything else sure so in
this study that we did what we were
trying to read out was what people were
holding in memory and essentially the
way they held it in memories that they
had to keep imagining this pattern so we
present one of two visual patterns
and then we say remember the first one
or remember the second one
and uh we could read out from a person's
brain activity which of the two patterns
they were holding in memory over time
this was work done with stephanie
harrison
from from the fact that they kept
thinking about that pattern if they
stopped thinking about it that signal
went away
and what was interesting about this
study was that we revealed information
using these decoding methods that was
never seen before so before it was
thought that
the visual cortex is silent it seems
pretty quiet and it's it's it goes
silent when you're looking at a blank
screen just thinking about something you
see visually
what we found is that if we measure the
overall level of brain activity the
amount of blood flow going to the visual
cortex it it fell back to the level of
what you would see if a person was
looking at a blank screen
but if we look at the detailed pattern
what we saw was a lot of information we
could read out what the person was
holding memory with with high accuracy
so tell me what this tell me what this
picture actually says
um you see
i'm assuming that the yellow and blue
dots are are the readout is that correct
they seem to be quite different and yet
you could identify
that
this person was remembering this
pink object i'm not sure what it is uh
and holding it in her memory and even
with that ver the you know i guess it's
18 variation in the uh
in the readout of the brain you said 82
83 accuracy 17 that's right so so this
is this is a schematic but what the
yellow and blue patterns show are the uh
the different chunks of the brain that
are voting essentially for
uh one pattern or another respond more
to one pattern or another and uh when
they're imagining one pattern another
their activity is biased
and so
it's not exactly the same remembering
it's seeing but it's similar enough that
we can predict with with pretty good
accuracy
what the person is is holding on into
memory and and the interesting thing is
that the level activity we see in the
brain the overall level is lower than
what you'd see if you ever looked at
anything even the faintest possible
image
and yet that information is still there
so it suggests that
thinking about something or imagining
something is is kind of like seeing it
but at such low levels of activity that
you would you'd never confuse it for
actual immediate perception it's it's
it's it's a faint echo of uh of of
actually seeing the real thing in a
sense any chance that you'll ever be
able to visually decode dreams
uh perhaps um a colleague of mine in the
previous study is working on an
interesting problem which is trying to
reconstruct what people are seeing and
it hasn't been done yet but the natural
question one would ask next is uh could
we ever reconstruct uh what a person is
is imagining i'll give you a flavor of
his study what he did was he would show
different flickering patches of light in
a 10 by 10 grid and sometimes it was
just different random patterns sometimes
they were on or off
and
you know the story a picture's worth a
thousand words
it's actually worth much more than a
thousand words with just a simple 10 by
10 grid and trust me you wouldn't pay
money to have 10 by 10 resolution on
your iphone or something like that but
with just a 10 by 10 grid how many
possible images can you make you can
make two to the power of 100 images if
we're just saying it's on or off so
that's that's a big number i don't know
what that is off the top of head but 2
to 100 is a big number
and
if you can see what he's done he's
trained on a bunch of random noise
patterns and he can spell out
later when he shows recognizable images
he can spell out from a person's brain
activity uh what the person saw so you
can see the
the word neuron being reconstructed from
a person's brain activity uh as sort of
a square of different sizes a plus sign
an x and uh in essence what he's doing
here is uh reconstructing what the
person saw
i call this again a fancy example of
brain reading is kind of cool but we
don't need a three million dollar
machine to uh
do what you could do simply looking over
the person's shoulder and see what they
saw but the next step might be could you
reconstruct what a person's imagining so
i'll just give a sample sort of sci-fi
thought
thought case imagine you were not
witness eyewitness to a crime and you
saw the suspect but unfortunately you're
a lousy artist you can't really draw
what you saw
would it be one day possible that the
person is imagining what they saw and
you could reproduce you know with
reasonable likeness what the person saw
that would be pretty handy
because as we said a picture's worth a
thousand words and we have a very hard
time translating what we've seen
into any any reconstructed form that
another person could experience so this
is this is about thought identification
in in both of your cases it's about
thought identification but it's it's
still
more or less limited to
the individual you figure out how that
individual's brain lights up and then
you can identify
how they uh
what they might be thinking on the basis
of how those scans light up this would
be a good time i think to show a clip of
what was done at uh carnegie mellon by
tom mitchell and marcel juiced and this
is also about thought identification
let's watch it and then i'd like you
guys to relate this experience to your
own work
what we're doing is trying to tie
the biology of the brain the neural
activity to the ideas that we're
thinking about
so justin is now being shown
these
uh word image pairs
there are total of eight distinct ones
and each one is going to be shown three
times
and that will be the data
that we'll be using
and the only information it'll have to
go on
is the brain image so from his brain
image for these numbers they'll have to
identify which one it is
now that we've collected the images from
justin's brain while he was thinking
about these eight words
we've asked the computer algorithm to
look at the brain imaging data that
we've collected and tell us which word
was which
the word was changed my
is chisel
so got chisel on the first guess
so in the next experiment what we're
doing
is uh
we're going to take a classifier that
was not trained using data from justin
instead it was trained using data from
other people
and we're going to determine
whether that classifier which has never
seen data from justin's brain before
can successfully determine
uh which word that he's looking at so
the first word
we've asked it to say
was the word i or was it closet
i think the word is i
okay so it was correct it got it this is
based entirely on other people's uh
brain activation
i think the word is apartment
i think that's it it got on 10 out of 10
in a two-choice
test it got a perfect score
now what this shows is that
other people represented these 10 items
rather similarly to the way
that justin did it means that all of us
to some extent when we think of a chair
or an apple or a hammer
or any physical object
very similar things are happening to our
brain
so it sounds like your work is more
extrapolatable
than than you might have thought or that
i might have thought is this is this uh
you know is this the direction that uh
you guys have been moving in all along
i think
i think that the um uh difference
between the cases that frank and i are
looking into in this case
is that we're more interested in subtly
different
uh thoughts so a closet um versus an eye
very different thoughts lots of
different associations
and the first of all these very
different cases are easier to read out
the more similar the patterns of brain
activity get the more difficult it is to
read out the information
and
also if you as i said earlier on if you
get into these very subtle fine-grained
details
then you
this kind of similarity between people
breaks down so then the idiosyncrasies
the differences associations the wiring
fine-grained wiring patterns and so on
they play a much bigger role so i think
if you were to try and find out which
which closet or whose closet or whose
eye and so on the person was thinking
about that would be much more difficult
but of course this is absolutely
fascinating research are some people
harder to scan than others
other some people's minds more cluttered
when asked to do uh
when asked to make a simple decision so
that you can scan them actually i once
had a very interesting uh radio
conversation with someone from bolivia
and it was the first time someone had
ever asked this question to me he said
he was very bubbly on the phone and he
said i am we have all these different
thoughts going on in our mind at the
same time and everything is happening in
parallel under uh how can we read out
all these different things and i think
it's true that these cases are would be
very difficult and we don't know how the
overlap of different thoughts in the
brain would kind of hinder us stop us
prevent us from decoding the information
but still um of course what we're
looking at are very simple scenarios so
these kind of real day situations real
everyday day-to-day situations the
typical ongoing daydreaming thought
content of your mind i think is going to
be very difficult to get out in
very the finest grain detail and uh and
as you say
as you say you don't want to put
electrodes into people's minds on the
other hand john donahue does and and as
a result you are actually able to work
on you know on the single neuronal level
you you get you can pinpoint single
neurons in order to create
motor responses
can you describe your work well so what
we're doing actually is going the other
direction we're trying to take thoughts
and turn them into actions and we're not
doing them for the fun of it but we're
actually trying to create devices or
applied technologies that can help
people who have a brain that works in a
body that doesn't they're not connected
to the outside world because they have a
spinal cord injury or a stroke
or other kinds of degenerative disorders
like als or multiple sclerosis
so what we're doing is
using at the finest scale now and you'll
see in a couple of minutes a description
of this uh taking at the finest scale
neuronal activity reading out intentions
to move and turning them in or decoding
them
into uh
in many cases a control of a movement of
a cursor so when you think about moving
your arm you'll move a cursor but we've
done other things too and i think maybe
if we start with the video from a 60
minutes clip
it was a show shown last year in 60
minutes this is a very short piece of it
and it'll show i think a nice
description of the brain gate system
which is a kind of neural interface or
brain computer interface that we're
developing for people with paralysis and
i'll just they'll they'll introduce
kathy who is
tetraplegic i mean she can't move her
arms and legs due to a stroke in the
part of her below her brain but above
her spinal cord so maybe we can have
that video first please
kathy hutchinson is among the first
humans to have her brain directly wired
to a computer
years ago kathy suffered a stroke that
left her mentally sharp but trapped
inside a paralyzed body and unable to
speak kathy volunteered to have the same
kind of sensors we saw in the monkeys
implanted in her motor cortex which
controls movement and is located right
on the surface of the brain
the sensors connect to the computer
through this plug on her head the system
is called braingate and it was created
by a team led by brown university
neuroscientist john donahue if you look
at this square
each one of these little black boxes is
the electrical signal coming from one
electrode in the brain and each one of
those is a neuron firing right it's its
electrical potential it lets out a one
thousandth of a second pulse we watch
together
as kathy showed us what she can do
there's a handful of icons that have
been placed on the screen here's google
the new york times boston globe and
here's mass general hospital stroke
service
we're seeing kathy
moving this cursor with nothing but her
mind
that's right she's thinking about the
movement of her hand and uh she's moving
the cursor much as if she had her hand
on a mouse so if a patient who's
paralyzed
thinks
move my left arm the brain fires those
neurons yes even though the arm does not
move yes it's very surprising
so uh this the show goes on but what i'd
like to show if you could just continue
with the next piece is that uh in the
end what we we said we can also control
real world devices not just cursors on a
screen so here's an example of kathy
controlling a wheelchair now we didn't
put her in it because we didn't know how
she would drive it
she was and she did in fact run over my
toe and hit the bookcase but but
what that shows that was wirelessly
connected from her brain directly to
this wheelchair showing that in fact you
could use brain power to imagine moving
something and then it would come to to
reality and be moved so anybody who saw
uh
the diving bell and the and the
butterfly right or or on a recent
uh episode of house locked-in syndrome
it's called uh
blinking was one way that was used to to
communicate uh a whole world has opened
up for this woman
right and we've shown this in four
patients that the ability to use the
output of the brain these neuronal
activities to to drive various kinds of
things like cursors if you put up that
slide please
what you can see
there we go it just shows you that the
basic system as it stands today so let
me emphasize it's at a very early stage
four people have been studied we just
got permission to study 15 more but what
you can see in this that first the red
circle on the left there is the what's
called the brain gate array and it looks
a little bit big but it's actually only
the size of a baby aspirin and it has
100 hair thin electrodes that go just
into the surface of your cerebral cortex
which is sort of an orange peel thick
rind on the outside of your cortex
outside of your brain
and that sits in the brain there's a
plug on the head as you saw in kathy
this is very primitive
we're working towards making one that's
wireless but it's not there yet that
elicits action potentials or these
spikes or these electrical impulses you
can see in the green oscilloscope trace
at the top and then you can see a
cartoon of of the wires coming out of
the head going into a card of
electronics where all of this magical
decoding where we interpret the impulses
coming out of the brain and put it into
a computer screen where the computer
thinks it's getting a mouse command
how does this relate to the thought
identification that's being done
by frank and john dylan do you do you
now obviously you're
you're not looking at a picture of a
picture you're not looking at the result
of thoughts you're actually down there
in real time well these are
reflections of thoughts they're a small
sample there are really millions and
millions of cells involved in generating
this activity we're looking at a tiny
sample of all of those cells because
these electrodes can only record from a
cell that's very very close to it so we
get a few cells a few dozen maybe a
hundred if we're lucky
from that though we can interpret and
and get quite a bit of control
and i think if we uh
we could well we can ask how far can we
go if you put up the next slide how much
information can you get or this next
video please if you say how much
information can you get out of the brain
here what you're watching is a monkey
playing catch
and that is uh what's called a motion
capture device all those little dots are
special illuminated objects that tell a
bunch of cameras where the arm is we mo
we capture that and we say okay that's
that's where the arm is and at the same
time we have that same array that's in
kathy in the arm area of this motor part
of her of the brain this is in a monkey
now and we ask the question how much can
we actually decode or read out from that
part of the brain
and what you can see here is a
reconstruction the ghosted look at it
looking in image is what the monkey was
actually doing and the shakier solid
color one is what we were decoding from
the brain and what's amazing and
actually surprising to us
is that we can decode really almost
everything that's going on as you reach
out and grasp an object so if a
paralyzed person were to have this array
in their brain they could potentially be
able to reach out and grasp if we could
control their muscles
with an artif with an artificial arm
well
a prosthetic arm a robotic arm or
perhaps even their own arm so as we we
get on in another couple of seconds
we'll move on to a demonstration where
we asked simply
uh kathy how well can you control a
virtual arm so here's kathy you can see
her head in shadow at the side there and
she's looking at a virtual arm and
instead of moving a cursor she's moving
that fingertip around on the screen and
you can see not only can she move the
arm around
she can also click by by
flexing her finger when she imagines
squeezing her hand so she can point and
click basically now what's incredible
about this is she's this is movement is
not occurring simply as a movement of a
cursor that arm is being driven by six
simulated muscles that behave just like
our real muscles do
so she's actually driving muscles that's
driving her arm well that's what we do
so someday what we hope is that we could
implant wires into the muscles
and stimulate the muscles under commands
from the brain so the wires and the
muscles already exist that has been done
there about several hundred people that
have wires in the muscles but they
control it with clicks from the outside
if you have brain gate a device like
brain gate driving the arm we would
actually be able to reanimate muscles
and people would be able to move again
people that are paralyzed so we build a
physical nervous system where the the
biological one is broken so if kathy had
had uh these stimulating wires in her uh
muscles she could actually move not very
elegantly should be able to move with
support around on a tabletop perhaps
grab a cup of water and bring it over to
her mouth and take a sip but remember
now she can't have a sip of water unless
someone brings it to her what about you
said you can't uh
you can recreate the the broken biology
what about broken eyes broken ears
so remember that so we're so what i just
spoke about was taking information out
of the nervous system and trying to
produce movement but what you just spoke
of was bringing information into the
nervous system and there are in fact a
number of uh cases where that's being
tried the most successful is the
cochlear implant in which a tiny
noodle-sized thread is threaded up into
the ear
and with electrical stimulation
of transduced sound so sounds are
transformed into patterns of electrical
stimulation it goes in and it bypasses
the lost parts of the ear and activates
the brain and surprisingly uh even with
eight channels of stimulation you can
replace 30 000 channels of the normal
brain so they're about 100 000 people
with cochlear implants with the eye the
earliest stages of testing is are now
happening about six patients have a very
very crude sense of light and dark
produced by retinal implants that
stimulate the back of their eye that
sends information up to the brain so
we're seeing this is all called
neurotechnology and really we're at the
beginning of this age where replacement
parts for a broken body can be derived
from physical components so this is
really a consequence of understanding
this code between the brain and and the
outside world of the or the inside of
the brain and the outside world
so when you look at jordy's glasses in
the next generation
do you see a real future there
well his glasses i think transduce
something into his eyes
i think they're sending impulses into
his brain yeah yeah so so in fact there
are several people who already have
devices like that and that
have they have a camera on the outside a
little chip in their eye and that is
giving them signals but not they're not
seeing a stage like this with color and
form and motion what they can see is if
there was a large black wall with a
white door they could tell that there
was a white door there sort of
and they're harnessing all the rest of
their brain power to do that
okay so we've now seen
a number of ways and and potentially an
infinite number of ways that we can
have the
privacy of our skulls violated for for
good or perhaps not for good and
and that's why i want to bring you in
because uh you've created this field of
neuroethics because you can clearly see
that there are ethical issues that will
have to be resolved before we can apply
the science that is now being developed
well i didn't create it single-handedly
it was a group of us but
for each of the kinds of different
neurotechnologies we've heard there are
different kinds of issues that come up
so if we start with fmri and imaging the
brain there are some very interesting
questions you brought up the issue of
privacy
but before i mention it i want to say
something more fundamental about it
in all of human history
from the time we crawled out of the
trees until modern times without a
single exception
ever ever anywhere
any information you got from another
human being you got from their
peripheral nervous system
language expression heartbeat sweating
it doesn't matter what it is you got no
information nor was there any way to
ever get any information directly from
the brain
about 10 years ago 15 years ago that
changed and now for the first time in
human history we can get information
directly from the brain so one of the
questions we need to ask ourselves is
what does that mean how does that matter
if it does matter at all i think it
matters a lot in turn it changes a lot
of things that may not at the beginning
be obvious
certainly there's the issue of privacy
the good news right now for fmri is you
can't coercively make someone go into an
fmri you have to cooperate you have to
lie still you have to think about what
they want you to think about
but it's not that far in the future in
which we might be able to get
information through fmri or by the way
through some other
techniques they're trying to use like
functional near infrared and other kinds
of techniques that are don't involve a
multi-million dollar big machine
where we might be able to begin to get
information from people's brains
remotely or covertly even possibly now
that's not now it's a possibility for
the future but it's there
so the privacy issue is going to be a
very very big issue and it's going to
have implications socially it's going to
have implications legally and i'll give
you an example of that in a moment but
the other thing i wanted to say about it
is
there's a tendency a lot of people have
to to worry about this a lot and i want
to emphasize that many of these
technologies will do enormous good and
will allow us if you take you know john
donahue's
people who are quadriplegic it will
allow
great therapeutic innovations in terms
of of understanding the way the brain
works some of the work
has been done to try to understand
learning disabilities and other things
so there's real great potential here and
and my concern is that we do this in a
way that makes sure that that as we move
along this path and and by the way
i got into this very early i started
reading the literature when it first
started coming out and i kept thinking
we're going to hit a wall that's as far
as we're going to be able to go and then
they made another breakthrough i said
well that's as far as we're going to be
able to go i'm telling you i've stopped
predicting that that's as far as we're
going to be able to go
each new paper each new breakthrough
makes me think someday we actually will
be able to apprehend very specific
thoughts from people's brains let me
i want to bring you in in just a moment
but i think
i want to give you something to react to
so can you talk to me a little bit about
what the
non-medical applications of this
thought identifica identification and
and brain machine interface technology
might be
i think
i think you're not miked right
okay
so for example um thinking that i want
my microphone to be turned on and it to
be turned on
now if i was to go to john donahue i'd
have the problem that you'd have to
drill a hole in my brain
my skull and
my skull exactly
and then
prong a little electrode grid into my
into my brain i think that shows that i
mean they're two different research
fields ultimately complementary research
fields on the one hand medical
applications invasive electrodes let's
try and get as much information as we
can for the benefit of the of the
patients on the other hand what can we
do non-invasively
with the non-invasive neuroimaging
technology that we have which is of
course still limited
and the kind of things i think we're
going to see
are very simple applications that don't
need us to kind of read out the
full-blown details of a person's
thoughts but something like a person is
lying yes or no or a person wants to buy
a car yes or no these kind of
applications i think are the
applications we're going to see
and
now we're not there at the moment we
can't i mean they're companies claiming
that they can already do this which is
of course
rather misleading
but
i think because these applications are
so simple simple yes no questions we
might be seeing them in the next 10 or
20 years and one thing to possibly even
kind of
an important variable in this is if
someone now was to invent a brain
imaging device that gets that neural
activity at a much finer level
then i think we'd see it even much
faster
so these are the kind of applications i
think we're going to see and of course
where we want to think uh if we want to
use them yes or no i guess for example
lie detection
not necessarily here in the usa
in europe for example where i live um i
mean people are i mean they hate lie
detectors they would never want to
invade in a person's mental privacy
which i think is problematic of course
because um you can also assist an
innocent person in demonstrating their
innocence so i mean
similarly i think lie detection is is a
is an interesting problem that some
people have made overly strong claims
about its potency and uh as these
methods get more powerful uh
they're two issues that come up one is
will it ever be accurate enough that
that we would have confidence that it's
doing it correctly and then the ethical
issue of is that innovation of privacy
and notions of the fifth amendment
and then also the notion of could one
voluntarily
choose to undergo a test and would that
be useful
i was always very much against lie
detection and that notion of that
technology and i got a rather poignant
letter from a person who was in prison
in georgia he was 60 something year old
and he said i was really interested in
this article i read about your research
and also about lie detection do you is
that allowed and is there any way i
could set up a test i got convicted for
a crime that i'm not guilty of i don't
even want to get out of jail i just want
to clear my name
and is there any means for me and and i
was struck by it and how personally it
was written that you know we have a lot
of people who who go to jail and and the
system by which we decide in a sense or
guilt is noisy uh how accurate would
such a system have to be before we would
consider uh allowing people to
voluntarily take a test and what would
our view of that in the sense that we're
reading a person's thoughts would we
want to go there is that
reading out an example of testimony or
is it evidence how we don't know how to
think about these ideas yet paul let me
give two examples of that um first the
fifth amendment i wrote a paper with a
student of mine who's at nyu law school
and told me she'd be somewhere in the
audience sarah stoller which we looked
at the question of the fifth amendment
so it's a very interesting thing the
fifth amendment is not a law against
self-incrimination it's a law against
testimonial self-incrimination
so if you can if i could incriminate
myself or if you could prove that i did
something by taking my blood or a hair
sample i have to give that even though
it's self-incrimination what you can't
force me to do is testify and there's a
lot of case law about this so let's
imagine for a moment that we're now in a
situation where you could brain image me
and get a piece of information from my
brain
that would convict me
is that
testimony the answer is it's not
testimony and it's not not testimony it
is something brand new that we have not
defined and i guarantee that at some
point in the next 10 years the supreme
court is going to have to decide whether
a piece of information gotten from the
brain is testimonial evidence or
non-testimonial evidence a second quick
example uh
you brought up racism or john dillon
brought up racism there's an interesting
study done also here in new york at suny
by liz phelps looking at people's brains
who had taken a paper and pencil test in
which was an embedded racism scale and
what she found that uh there were these
white males were put into the scanner so
were black males but it was the white
males that she found in effect
and she flashed pictures of known white
males
politicians sports figures movie stars
unknown white males known black males
and known unknown black male faces and
what she found was that there was a
correlation
between how these men did in racist
ideation in this hidden scale that they
didn't know they had taken and amygdala
activation and the amygdala is the part
of the brain that responds to anxiety
and excitation when they saw and only
when they saw unfamiliar black male
faces
now imagine for a minute that we could
turn that around and
liz phelps hates when you do this
because this wasn't part of her study
but imagine if you could put men
into a scanner not having taken that
scale and you could show them pictures
and say uh-huh his amygdala is reacting
when he sees unfamiliar black male faces
this is a man that has some level of
racist ideation well some people could
see that as an empirical measure of
racism and in certain court cases the
question of hate crimes and degree of
racism and people who actually have
tried to use you know uncontrolled
racist rage as an excuse to get away
from performing hate crimes has been
very very much a part of the way in
which certain court cases have gone so
there's some very interesting kinds of
information and questions that are going
to arise as we become better and better
at reading the brain
so uh
what are
you there are several legal issues i
know there but they're not currently
being considered because this
this technology is no longer is not yet
available well
we haven't talked about
we've only talked about a very small
sample of the kinds of interesting
questions that new brain technologies
are raising for example
how do we
use a brain image of a an offender's
brain to
suggest that there were mitigating
circumstances this is actually something
that has been in a number of court cases
and is very current so i'm a lawyer i
have a client the client did something
terrible i bring in my brain image of
the client's brain you say here's an
abnormality in his brain or here's a
tumor that's why he did it courts
actually don't know what to do with that
information right now i'm not sure
anybody even the experts don't know what
to do with that information but as we
begin to learn more and more about the
brain people are going to bring those
kinds of things in and they already are
just not the level of things that the
sophisticated kind of science that that
the panel is doing these things are
already beginning to come into courts
and the courts have to grapple with them
i don't even know if these exist but the
thing that people always bring up as as
an object of
along these lines is the airport scanner
the one that will be you know passed
over you to determine whether or not
you're a terrorist uh there are there
are people who have uh who
seem to be
advertising devices of this nature and i
don't know whether they're real or you
know whether this is just a joke or what
the state of these things are but uh
could you comment on this have you
encountered this scanner issue
i could i could
i could uh
give you an example of two people who
came to me in berlin one day they
knocked them they knocked on my door and
they had this device it was a webcam
uh tied attached to a computer they came
from russia and they had this really
weird device
and it basically measured people
um this webcam and then they looked at
the frequency with which the outer part
of the body was jiggling around
and they made this claim from some very
old physiology book that something like
if you jiggle fast then you're likely to
commit a crime and then you're kind of
nervous and so on and i was i thought
this is a load of nonsense and then
uh they told me there's actually an
operation in two airports uh in in the
in in russia and i thought
this clearly shows that any kind of
technology also the technology that
we're developing needs some kind of
clear
standards we need to as a scientific
community develop standards when people
can truly claim that they can perform a
certain thought reading or thought
decoding thing say for example whether
they can really decode whether a person
is lying or not or whether they really
know that someone is going to buy a car
or that they're racist etc and i think
this is really important because the
current way in which this information is
used in courts and we actually had a
long discussion about this
recently as well with some lawyers from
the u.s
is that you just show for example an
abnormality and there's no causal
connection that you have to demonstrate
there it's kind of a cast sufficient
doubt
and um i think this is very problematic
we have to show a clear way of linking
this technology and really specifying
the amount of information we can get out
of this information get out of these
technical measurements
has any go ahead frank regarding brain
scanning well i do know that the us
military's interested in that and have
have uh information on that uh so
they're definitely interested in it i
don't think any systems currently works
very well one example system would be
infrared measures you know are you flush
under the skin because you're nervous
and the infrared camera would pick that
up a little more
and i think what that remote technology
and current fmi research uh when they
try to study lie detection both suffer
from this fundamental flaw we don't
really know we're not really reading up
truth and lie states from the brain
that's not really what's being read out
at this stage like we can read out the
person seeing a face or they're seeing
this pattern of lines what's being read
out is the emotional arousal that goes
with the lie or the
cognitive thought of oh where were you
last night the the extra thoughts that
the person's having to come up with the
excuse and so it's either the cognitive
extra thought or the emotion but not the
lying per se so if you're asked a
question about you know did you do this
and you feel nervous because you didn't
but your friend did or if you're asked
did you do this and you know that the
person who's interrogating you strongly
believes that you're likely to be guilty
whether you are or not we don't know how
that will affect the emotional senses of
your brain or how you'll think and
construe the question so we really don't
know when we read out brain activity
that's correlated with lying whether
that's lying per se or something that
goes along with it and these remote
technologies are tapping into the same
non-verbal non-conscious
behaviors that are
signs of of nervousness anxiousness
suspicious behavior uh but if you're a
targeted group and you're racially
profiled you know if i'm uh you know
of islamic descent and passing through
security and of the right age i might be
nervous just because i look like a
potential suspect
in in terms of lie detection some of the
lie detection technology not the airport
technology does try to look at actual
patterns in the brain and see if we can
detect what's different about lies but
as frank said sometimes what we're
detecting is if i say how old are you
and you say i'm 30 it's a one-step
process if you decide to lie you think
you think at some level very quickly i'm
30 i'm going to lie about this what
should i pick i'll pick 28 and then you
say 28 and what a lot of these brain
detection technologies may be seeing is
are those extra steps and what that
means of course is that you could train
yourself perhaps not to take those extra
steps there are two companies now that
are incorporated that are trying to
offer some of these lie detection
technologies to the public but these
technologies are are still very early
there are only a
handful of published papers on them
they've never been they're mostly tested
on undergraduates and universities like
most of the things we know we know about
people from 18 to 21
and you know not on people with
psychopathology not on con men not on
pathological life not on a lot of the
people that you would actually see out
there and so
this is a perfect example of what john
dillon was saying we need very very
strong standards in place about how
these technologies are going to be used
because right now there are none
anybody could set these kinds of
companies up and use these technologies
and it is pretty frightening so john
donahue are you like completely off the
hook here ethically because you help
paralyzed people
some extent i can claim that yes no but
i think
we do have to be uh considerate of that
we have a particularly vulnerable
population
and in terms of thinking about the
ethics it's very important to say if a
person is paralyzed if i start making
false claims about how much we can do
and i hope everyone recognized that i
was very cautious about how early we are
in developing these technologies that
being in a kind of position of power we
could would mislead people and a you
know a person with more malicious intent
could try to convince individuals to
have these implants so they could learn
more about their brain or do or do other
things so so again i think that there's
a potential uh for misuse we are of
course under great uh uh control from
regulatory bodies
and hospitals that that watch over these
things
but i think you know and as the
scientists uh have a moral
responsibility ethical responsibility to
to make sure that the patients that will
receive these devices will understand
them i think i just one other thing to
get back to the other issue too i just
wanted to say um that a lot of these
so far a lot of these technologies are
really uh probabilistic that is
different people have different
reactions the p300 wave that we talked
about this brainwave that has a novelty
response that uh is in the brain i think
there's
a second here this was okay this was a
conversation that these guys no they
heard they heard about this novelty
response during the during the thing but
but a p300 is a response in your brain
to seeing something novel and it's just
could be recorded on the outside of your
head
and uh uh there's a i think 15 or 20
percent
it's people are interested in it as a
lie detector that did you see it did you
not uh there should be a change in the
response and in some people it's quite
robust but in something like 15 or 20 of
the people it doesn't exist at all you
can't find it
and uh so so i i think it has what i
call an airplane test you know if eight
out of ten times it's it works is that
okay well would you get on a plane that
eight out of ten times it would make it
to its destination i think that's not a
valid test for me so i think you can
talk about that but let's talk about
uh john's work a little bit we are for
the first time now hardwiring the brain
into computers and one of the questions
i asked john was when he first started
doing this was that computer connected
to the internet
because if it was for the first time in
history someone's brain became a node on
the internet
and we can imagine what the
if his subjects as they can can move
that cursor around the screen well they
can also click on google and they can go
into facebook and they can begin to use
their brain to interact as you use your
computer to interact and there are no
particularly horrifying ethical
implications of that but it is the
beginning the first shot across the bow
of an integration of information
technology into our brains and with our
brains they are all not john's work but
they're already looking at prosthetic
hippocampal chips these are chips that
would be actually implanted in the brain
the hippocampus is the memory um
encoding part of the brain and some
people have lesions in their hippocampus
or their hippocampus is damaged and
that's why you get people who can't form
long-term memories there are movies
about the memento and was that 50 first
dates or something like that
depending on which kind of movie you
watch the art movies or the popular
movie um and they're actually now
thinking about taking a chip putting it
in the brain so that information will go
into the hippocampus we get bypassed
through the chip
bypassing the lesion or in the brain and
then put back into the hippocampus well
think about that for a second imagine
that that technology works and we now
have the first person with that
technology we now have information
technology computer chips that are
integrated into the very functioning of
the brain
and that's not a thousand years from now
or a hundred years from now that is
right around the corner and we have to
and we have a lot of that changed our
relationship with the internet but i
wonder whether or not that that really
raises an ethical issue there's a lot
here that seems to me to be somewhat
similar to
search and seizure in other words we
have laws against people coming into our
house if they don't have uh the right
warrants i would assume that we would
require the same warrants to have them
rummaging through our brains we would
but here's my here's my concern i'm
actually a radical on this issue
i believe that our skulls are absolute
domains of privacy that is i don't
believe that the state should be allowed
to come in and get information from my
brain even with that warrant they can
come into my house they can search my
house i'm for an absolute right to
cognitive privacy and that means that
under no circumstances should anyone be
able to should the court or the state or
anyone else be able to mandate that the
private content what does a right to
privacy mean
if it doesn't mean the absolute right to
the contents of my own thoughts what if
somebody wishes to have their thoughts
rifled to be exonerated and well that's
different if i voluntarily want this
technology i'm all for it but you didn't
ask the question that most people ask
when i say that which is what about the
terrorists with knowledge of the bomb in
manhattan and that really is where the
rubber hits the road about this there
will be times if you always have
waterboarding
but what if it can be done
non-invasively right what if but exactly
what if you could do it without torture
you just have to stick them in an mri
machine and you could get some piece of
information
and of course that's where the real
problem happens will we allow it in
those circumstances and if we'll only
allow it in exceptional circumstances
how will we begin to define exceptional
circumstances and we've seen
over and over again the erosion of those
limits when people begin to define all
kinds of things as exceptional so this
is something as a society we're going to
have to work out but i really believe
that it's going to all happen very soon
and that it's very important for
everybody to think about where they
would want those limits set because this
is going to be a conversation that as a
society our society and and germany and
every other society is going to have to
figure out where they're going to set
the limits on these technologies does
anybody on this panel want to argue with
paul about his absolutism because that
would be cool
on on the importance of keeping what's
in our heads uh private and and of
course uh
the notion of of of of
of the right to silence uh however
here's an interesting problem as
technology advances and we did point out
the problems of using fmi to detect lies
uh but let's say
in the future it gets better and we do
get to the source of
uh the brain areas that are predictive
of lying and let's say the technology is
so good it's 99.99
accurate you can let's say uh
somehow they they test it somehow and
they confirm that that's true let's just
take that as a thought experiment this
raises an interesting problem of people
who then voluntary consent to the tests
and those who do not how would the
people who voluntarily choose not to
take the test be perceived by the courts
or let's say if it's not even at the
court level case uh civil action cases
or uh ceos regarding you know stock
issues people who take the fifth now
risk you know run the risk of uh
arousing suspicion but you know tough
luck
right true but with 99.99 accuracy it it
weights the the card quite a bit as to
wondering why you know why why would
they they not take the test if we ever
get to that point there was an
interesting uh decision
in which uh clarence thomas wrote a side
comment and it was about
polygraphy and lie detection and he
wrote something interesting that
he wrote
even if we were to have an effective lie
detector in his view it would never be
admissible in court because it usurps
the job of the jury whose sole
responsibility it is to determine the
truth or lie of the of the
plaintiffs so that's a really
interesting
i mean it wasn't the majority opinion it
was just a throwaway comment because
they didn't have an accurate lie
detector yet
it is interesting and i and you know
it's so interesting and i don't want to
digress from the the main part of this
conversation but if we're talking about
technology supplanting a traditionally
human function yeah we can talk about
you know umpires and baseball and
and you know
instant replay right i mean the fact is
if the truth is out there why do we
stick with the antiquated system of
trusting human beings
so i i think that the uh
that right so
paul was bringing up the idea of
replacement parts for the brain what if
we had a full brain that was a
replacement that is we could reproduce
the whole thing in fact i think one
thing that that everyone is sort of
missing
is that all of these studies that we do
is what's called neurophysiology it's
what we've been doing for about 100
years trying to pick apart how the brain
is actually working
and when you really understand how
something works you can replicate it if
you could replicate a human brain it
could be if i could replicate your brain
exactly would it take the same position
the same strong position or would it
take a different position
so and we would argue about what it is
about brains that make them slightly
different why twins aren't identical
truly in the way they think and the way
they behave
so i think you know there may be a
breakthrough in understanding enough
about how the brain works that we could
make a full replacement part it'll
probably be the most revolutionary kind
of event that occurs because then you
will be having full conversations with
your internet computer and it'll make
decisions that you can argue about all
day long but i have one caution about
that i mean we're very cerebrocentric in
modern science we really believe the
brain if you took my brain and and took
john's out and put my brain in john's
head aside from that organism right
there all of a sudden becoming less
intelligent than it is right now
doubt it
most people would say that's paul not
john presumably would have my memories
my ideas would think of my wife as its
wife and my kids as its kids um face-off
but there's a problem with that and that
is we're all convinced or most of us are
convinced that that's true but that is a
very recent
cultural
and historically
situated view of the brain in throughout
most of history and also even today in
other cultures people don't think of the
brain that way in japanese culture for
example for example the um the site of
personhood is thoracic it's in it's in
the abdomen it's not in the brain and
that's why you have such trouble with
cadaveric transplant in japan because in
japanese culture a body that's lying
there where the heart is beating and
blood is suffusing through the organs is
not dead even if the what even if it's
what we call brain dead so and that's
why when you commit supoku you
disembowel yourself you don't cut your
head off because that is where you kill
yourself that is where you destroy
personhood so the idea that we're all
brain our personality and our thoughts
and our memories everything is only and
and uniquely in the brain it's something
that we take for granted but we may end
up being surprised someday when we
actually can replace brains or when we
understand the nervous system better to
discover that there's much more of a
somatic
part to who we are as people than right
now neuroscience seems to suggest
does that do you encounter that at all
john i mean i know you
your entry point is the brain but you
know we know that there are more
uh
neural endings in your stomach and in
your alimentary canal than there is in
your brain and we know and we know what
sense how sense memory affects the way
that we
not just feel about things but how we
think about things do you
in in reattaching those connections do
you find links in surprising places
well that's the idea what i'm talking
about not really no
i was but you did you did evoke a few
thoughts i think that so just to say one
thing is that one thing that surprised
me is we think of the cerebral cortex as
one of the crowning glories of
specialized brains all the thoughts
going on up there
and uh when matthew in particular and we
sat with him and he was controlling the
cursor on a screen so he's sitting there
thinking what's coming out as being
translated he's controlling the cursor
if you asked him first of all you know
what's going on in your head well each
day he'd have a different story he would
make up stories about how his brain was
working just like i think if you know if
you asked a little kid you know when you
pick up the toothbrush in the morning
and brush your teeth how does your brain
make your hand do that they would just
make up some story so it was interesting
to us that that he had no insight into
what that part of his brain was actually
doing it's sort of functioning but it's
very active there's no no feedback so i
think the brain is actually operating
and doing performing all kinds of
actions and even at the level this
highest level where consciousness is
supposed to be taking place the things
are going on and you have no idea what's
actually happening there is it true we
only use 10 of our brains completely
wrong and nobody knows where it came
from
a good game is to ask all your friends
where they got what their number is and
have them write it on a piece of paper
because it goes from i think two or
three percent up to
uh
50 or something like that but i think
the experience now is that uh you know
the brain is a pretty active place it's
going we're doing a lot all the time and
the fmri data i think will help support
that and certainly the direct recordings
we do supports it
do you guys think that we're some
where is do you see a limit
is there a limit to what we can know
about the brain
and is it will do you
as you look forward what is the ultimate
goal in your research even if you're if
you don't live to see it in 200 years i
mean do you think that ultimately we'll
be able to map the brain and read the
messages
very clearly very granularly that we'll
be able to know
everything about
how a person feels at a given moment
from what how their brain lights up well
i think the big difficulty that nobody
at the moment has really got a good idea
how to address it is how
to understand and use the language of
the brain
so
most techniques that are used are brute
force techniques you find this pattern
of brain activity this thought and you
find this spike pattern
the person is thinking of a leftward
movement this spike pattern person is
thinking of a rightward movement
but i mean what we really need to
do in order to read out
all the possible thoughts a person has
is we need to understand the syntax and
semantics not just of the person's
thoughts but also but also but also in
their brain and i don't think at the
moment we have very good ideas for
example
language has a feature that is called
compositionality
dog bites man just take a very simple
sentence
now that involves a thought about a dog
as an actor
in a scene it involves um an action
biting and involves an object that
suffers from this is man so
the meaning is composed out of
kind of
elements of meaning that you can also
reuse in different sentences for example
you can go dog goes for a walk or
something like that um or
something
man bites hamburger so all these
elements can be reused in different
components and as components in
different meanings and i think this is
actually this this aspect of
compositionality of meaning
this is something that i don't think
neuroscience has a clear idea to this at
the moment it's not even clear how you
would go about looking at
this couldn't we take our cues from
computer languages
yeah but computer language is different
because they're fundamentally symbolic
so you have a symbol and the symbol gets
meaning uh by well definition and by
certain rules with which it's processed
but in the brain we don't know what
these rules are and we don't have
symbols but we have activation patterns
like half the brain or the whole brain
involved in a specific mental uh process
so do you think the brain will always
prove the language of the brain will
always prove elusive or will we crack
that code
i'm not saying we couldn't crack it but
i think at the moment we don't even have
an idea how to do that
but think of the magnitude of the
problem there's something like 10 to the
10th neurons in your uh brain as frank
said that's a really big number each one
of those neurons has about 10 000
contacts called synapses on them and
each one of those tickles a little bit
the neuron and how when a couple of
hundred or a thousand or so all
cooperate together they make that neuron
as another independent little brain
active and it interacts with some other
neuron and so really to understand what
the brain was doing you'd have to look
at how all of those interactions were
occurring so you think of 10 to the 10th
times 10 to the fifth is so many
interactions that it's unfathomable to
me that we'll ever look at we'll know
how a brain works but we'll never know
how your brain works
i thought that we had mapped sections of
the brain already
am i am i wrong about that no no we know
a lot about parsilation so as i showed
you we know where to go to pick up the
signals about the arm
but in fact when you just don't know
what else is going on in there in that
section there's a lot of other things
going on in fact the more we look as i
showed you the the monkey's arm reaching
out in space and our ability to get all
this information about the whole arm the
the sort of traditional view was that
little piece of the brain that we're
studying is only interested in what your
wrist does and doesn't know anything
about the rest of the body that's just
absolutely not true what that movie
shows is that that piece of the brain
has a big conversation going on with how
do you want to put your arm out in space
and we don't know how it really thinks
about it it's got some complex language
and mixed up in that is some kind of
noise going on and there's even an
argument is all that
unpredictable stuff a kind of noise or
is it really the brain communicating and
we don't know
so i mean i guess to conclude this
session uh we have
such an amazing prospect before us for
healing and uh for
if we can download our our brains
something close to immortality and we
also have the opportunity for the
ultimate invasion of privacy
so you know what would each of you want
the people here to take away from this
session
paul you start
a small question
yeah it's a very that's a very big
question
we need to understand the nature of the
work that's going on when i talk to
audiences about what's going on in
neuroscience and and i go across there
are a lot of other very interesting
things going on that we haven't had time
to deal with here and i try to show them
the overall picture
of our ability to begin to predict
what people are thinking or behaving or
their traits or states or abilities and
things um it's really quite profound
that we've done this in such a short
time because fmri for example hasn't
been around very long and yet in that
short time we've really discovered a lot
about the brain so my major message to
people is
we're going to have to make a lot of
decisions
we haven't really put a lot of attention
on this there's a tiny fraction of the
attention that has been paid for example
to ethical legal and social implications
of genetics
with which we spent millions and
millions of dollars to look at that we
spent
a fraction of that to look at the
ethical legal and social implications of
neuroscience and yet what's happening in
neuroscience is much more immediate and
in some ways more powerful than what is
happening right now in genetics maybe 30
40 years from now that won't still be
true but
it is certainly true our ability to
manipulate the brain in human beings for
example is much more powerful than our
ability to manipulate human genetics for
example
and yet we're not really paying it the
attention it deserves so my takeaway
message is we have to be vigilant as a
society as these things begin to happen
and make sure that we're thinking very
clearly about where we want to set
boundaries and by the way who gets to
set those boundaries is it the court
um are we gonna you know am i going i
have two teenage daughters and i come
home one day and the car is dented and
both of them say they didn't do it do i
get to haul them off to no lie mri
put them in a brain scanner which is a
real company
so you know these are
these are questions that were you you
want to get a job at the bank and they
say i'm sorry before you can be a teller
we have to brain scan you i mean are
these going these going to be things
that we are as a society are going to
allow or are we going to restrict it to
you know guantanamo bay and abu grave is
that where we're going to allow these
kinds of technologies to take place
these are decisions that we are going to
have to make fairly soon and they're
going to be very complicated and they're
going to be a lot of subtle aspects to
them and i would like people to think
about these things to pay attention in
the media when these things show up and
also an appeal that we need to be more
vigilant about studying them and and
more resources have to be put into
understanding the implications of these
technologies
well so i think one of the keys
to follow up on paul's and to follow up
on all of these
ideas is science education i think that
that it's it's really critical that
people come to understand what science
has done what they're capable of doing
as we're trying to do here
but but i think the fear
trepidation of what science where
science is going to take us comes from a
lack of understanding one of the things
that has really shocked me
in in presenting data about our trial is
when i talk about how an age of
neurotechnology is already here and you
say okay how many people have had an
electrode stuck into their brain to
treat the symptoms of parkinson's
disease because you can stimulate the
brain and get rid of the shaking and
tremor and rigidity of parkinson's and
even with uh you know well-informed
audiences who are maybe biologists but
not uh not physicians numbers come up
like 10 or 20 people have had this
voluntarily done the answer is it's
closer to 50 000 have done it so there
are huge numbers of people who have
already this is a field that's already
here so i think you should understand
that you should understand what good it
does and what the implications are but
this is really a mission of scientists
communicating to the public and also the
public's responsibility to understand
where we are as a field
what i find
what i find so interesting about uh
neuroscience and i think
we will make progress in understanding
the code of the brain uh we'll have a
better idea of how brain states map on
to mental states the the really hard
problem is how does it work and how does
the brain function that will be you know
many many decades of work i think there
will be major advances on being able to
read out mental states from brain states
and for me what's what's interesting and
intriguing about it is that as as we get
closer i'm one of my most frequent fmi
subjects i scan my own brain i look at
my brain and i know what i was thinking
at the time when i did the experiment
and then i look at my brain and say oh
that's what i was thinking over there i
feel like i'm closer to understanding
what my conscious experiences are how i
think feel see the world what it means
to imagine something and i think that
neuroscientists will provide a
perspective complementary to art and
sort of understanding our own conscious
experiences a sort of complementary
symphony to what's been done on the art
side we will have new perspectives on on
what it means to uh to be human and and
one aspect i think is very interesting
is that there's not just one me or one
brain what we will discover as we
started the brain is that there are many
meeks many many me's you could say um
and and so the case of the police
officer and the scanning the amygdala is
an interesting example let's say if you
scan my brain i don't have a boss
because i'm a professor but let's see if
he's getting my brain in and it said oh
i hate my past and if you ask the
question would you like to kill your
boss maybe that brain scan would say yes
uh there's a visceral party that would
actually enjoy
seeing the act of my boss die but there
might be a cognitive part of me that
would never ever do that so there are
many me's to the brain and many states
and i think what we'll discover as we
study brain states more and more is that
the brain's incredibly complex it's like
a competition between many areas trying
to decide what we do and i look forward
to seeing how we learn about that
well i'd say that um
i think neuroscience is in a transition
phase at the moment i mean myself only
been in neuroscience for 10 years well i
mean i can observe a transition
where neuroscientists are beginning to
realize that what their research is
kind of yielding is also has technical
applications
and i think this is something that um
uh the field it not just the public has
to realize but also the field itself has
to realize people have to realize that
if i do research on for example neuro
correlates of racial prejudice this
might also be used for some kind of
application for like a racial bias
detector or something so i think um it
also needs a wider acceptance in the
neuroscience community to think about
that
consequences well
on an ethical sense yes but also to
think what can we what kind of practical
things can we do with our research you
know i mean a lot of the time people are
uh kind of uh locked away in an ivory
tower and to do anything related to
applications is considered dirty it's
impure
and
i think that's something the field might
want to realize that there's a huge
potential uh buried there as well
and
on the other hand i'd like to point out
as to the risks of this technology i'd
like to point out that so far as i know
the us is the only country in the world
that has actually
previously
previously
legislation
um related to the use of thought
decoding technology and that is the
so-called employee polygraphy protection
act and this is of course not a brain
scanner but it's related to a polygraph
so very old lie detector that uses
arousal to measure
when you're lying
and we of course know it doesn't work
that well but still it shows that
there has been the need to regulate the
use of this technology because i think
in the 1970s when this was
passed early 1980s
companies were trying to use this
technology on employees to for example
find out if they really had a loyal
um uh
thoughts disposition to the to the
company say in a job interview or you
might want to use it if something was
stolen you might subject all your staff
to uh to a lie detector and it was
considered important um then to pass
legislation that regulates these cases
and now you're not allowed to use a
polygraph unless you're a government
contractor i think fbi and things like
that so then you can
and i think it just shows that if you
can isolate a specific case that as a
society you don't want to use
then
you can pass legislation it can be quite
efficient
all right
john dylan haynes thank you very much
frank tong john donahue paul rude wolfie
thank you very much and thank you for
being here